do you believe a screenwriter should
write their first draft as quickly as
possible just kind of regurgitate it out
of themselves and then revise from there
you're talking about the vomit draft
aren't you all right we have such nice
expressions for it yes I do and I urge
my students not to look back that's
where the perfection starts to come in
and they stop up their writing process
and they have these beautiful four
stacks and then they never go any
further so yes by all means
right to the end and then you can go
back in and you can start honing it and
chiseling away at it or fattening it up
make it better but right to the end so
if they plan to do a 90 page script
don't don't stop in the middle and make
sure that it's okay they've got to just
get it all out right right barrel
forward I think I think so many people
make the mistake of going back and
rereading what they wrote the day before
polishing that up and only moving this
much further we don't have enough time
you know we only set so much writing
time in the day you've got to make as
much use of that as you can press
forward is there a time frame for
writing this first script I think that
time frame is is personal it really
depends on where you fit it in your life
you know I've made my whole philosophy
of teaching is writing in 10-minute
increments because of being a busy
person myself and knowing that my
writers are busy so I do believe that
whatever time you have you can make the
best use of it as long as you focus
you